dieser motorradfahrer was ist los mit
dem beliebten freunde willkommen zu
einer wunder
ja ich weiß ich habe versucht ganz hoch
zu sprechen aber ich hab's nicht
hingekriegt ich bin hier wieder mit
meinem ganz coolen weihnachts kinder am
start
kann sein dass man auch mit zwei
verschiedene farben haben bin ich
betrunken oder sind dass das sind oder
nicht sind das zwei verschiedene farben
oder weg das nur weil meine augenlider
vor und ich muss eben schnell noch ein
blog auswählen ich bin einfach ich bin
mit dem bieten ich bin ich bieten wenig
bieten war es die richtige entscheidung
war es was das habe ich in mir drin was
ist das denn da als auch egal spiel die
ganze zeit in die 25 in diesem app 5
modus ding man wird mit kacke ich gehe
jetzt einfach mal wurde das kann die
seien hier ich muss auch irgendwo kann
ich mir nicht irgendwo hier irgendwo
hinstellen oder irgendwie was machen
oder so ich brauch mal anstellen
komischen im versteck hier weil ich
wollte meine lieben freunde über ein
thema reden was eventuell mal ganz
interessant ist und was mir auch auf dem
herzen liegt ich stelle mich jetzt
einfach mal hierhin und anderen kann ich
mich ja hier irgendwie so hinstellen und
dann seht ihr das seht ihr mich einfach
und zwar wollte ich über das thema
economy class mich umbringen das kann er
nicht sein wenn ich die ganze zeit nur
komische plattner fresse aber jo sucht
und findet nicht wie ich später mal ist
der der sich als echt blöd der kann doch
kommt hört mich so und jetzt können wir
noch in der richtigen ansicht spielen
also ich wollte über ein thema reden was
ihm ihr letzter aufgefallen ist was bin
ich zu gesendet wurde aber was mir
aufgefallen ist und zwar der style von
anderen youtube an und die leute mit dem
aussehen von youtube an umgehen obwohl
es eigentlich überhaupt nicht relevant
ist und zwar ist es mir besonders
aufgefallen bei der jugendmesse in dort
man bei der wir nicht irgendwie uns
angekündigt hatten oder angemeldet haben
oder so als youtuber sondern einfach
spontan hingefahren sind also paar guten
sturm ii und der bruder von sturm und
ich da trafen auch einen coolen die lok
zu gemacht wo ich einfach mega müde bin
weil ich einfach irgendwie paar stunden
geschlafen tag vorher noch feiern waren
und alles aber die müsste auch gar nicht
sehen aber es geht um was anderes und
zwar war es dort zu lass dich nieder
einmal gefragt wurde von einer jahr kann
ich vielleicht meine haare anfassen da
denke ich mir erst mal so
das geht jetzt war schon ein bisschen
weit so dass es genau so wie ja kann ich
mal eben
meine nase an einem pulli abwischen oder
fürs mit ihr zu weit gegriffen aber
irgendwie ja so umarmen ist ja noch ganz
geht ihr eigentlich noch so obwohl das
auch schon krass ist weil ich danach
erst mal krank war weil ich irgendwie
tausende von leuten umarmt hat und
irgendwie war krank und ich danach auch
buch jedenfalls finde ich es geht zu
weit wenn man sagt ja mal was anderes an
oder irgendwie sobald das war da auch so
also ich habe eine jacke von redmark
glaube ich um die machen so jacken die
meistens länger sind sag ich mal von der
länge her außenverteidiger zog
motorradfahrer rum und will einfach
wahrscheinlich nur aufmerksamkeit oder
der weiß dass ich gerade einen videodreh
und denkt sich jetzt komm ich ärgert ihn
mal den später die spucke weg
ich finde einfach wieder keinen blog ich
bin ein sehr sehr guter seeker schlag
herum
ich habe mich am block bleibt doch wo
sehen sie ich habe hier immer karten
blog das kann man nicht einfach nicht
weg ist ich habe dennoch ich habe da
noch geredet mehr noch ein blog
die sind ja alle nur hier oben die pizza
das ist ja mal ein richtiges versteckt
ich wollte eigentlich nur sagen dass mir
das ganze nicht so weit geht werde ich
mal aber auf der you messe war es halt
so dass dann leute sagen sie ja keiner
anfassen ich dachte mir so weil wenn
leute da sind so zuschauer und so und
quasi ihr so meine freunde die zuschauer
weil wenn ihr mich zuschauer zeit wenn
ihr mir zuschauer
seid ihr quasi vom humor drauf und vom
charakter her so ähnlich wie ich weil
sonst würdet ihr euch nicht gefallen und
deswegen oft komme er klar laub system
arbeitet man will ja dann auch nicht
nein sagen wenn man sagt ja auch bei
autogrammen und so immer so ja ja klar
kriegs ein autogramm und so wenn die
extra dafür da hingekommen sind und so
aber ich war dann auf jeden fall und
dann wollte da immer meine haare
anfassen ich dann erstmal so ja klar das
machen dann reißen die dann meinen
haaren herum und andere auch karmann de
30 an den haaren rum und machen da alles
mögliche und ich habe einfach so ganz
normale haare und jeder kommt so auf
einmal an und so und waren halt auch
recht jüngere leute dabei so 14.15
durchschnitt würde ich sagen
und die waren halt alles ein bisschen
noch nicht so also die waren halt alle
so ja okay er hat uns erlaubt ihr reist
an seinen haaren rom höhe
so nach dem motto das war ein bisschen
14 sekunden hinter zu kriegen oder oder
schreibt das bak ich da unter diesem
baum fest naja egal ich wollte sagen
dass das ging schon soweit dann habe ich
aber nachher noch mitbekommen am
beispiel tadel sagt er jetzt einfach mal
und mal andere haben ihre haare gefärbt
und alle lästern dieser motorradfahrer
was ist los mit dem okay wir haben
verloren aber naja dann rede ich noch
eben hier in der lobby ein wenig weit
würde ich stehe in der neue spiel ich
bin ja kein kein ball mehr auf half
deswegen 84 26 sekunden hat das ganz
geil
jedenfalls habe ich das damit bekommen
dass er alle meinten so wie kann man
seine haare färben das ist ja mal so
scheiße aus und ich denke einfach nur
leute das ist ein opfer dieses business
oder wie heißt dieses englische zitat
weil das geht euch quasi nichts an ich
meine rein theoretisch fahrzeug in
sachen denke mir mal entweder man man
kennt halt den hintergrund nicht
eventuell hat sich irgendwie die haare
gefärbt oder dies oder das gemacht weil
vielleicht jemand aus der familie
gestorben ist und dann denkt man sich ok
der hat die haarfarbe da gibt's ja die
verrücktesten sachen weil man mich ich
möchte damit halt nur sagen also ich
möchte damit jetzt nicht sagen dass
fontane jemand aus der familie gestorben
ist oder irgendwann schwach sein oder so
was das möchte ich gar nicht sagen dass
halt nur ein beispiel
man kennt die hintergründe nicht und die
andere sache ist halt auch einfach
dieses dass es nicht euer business es
geht euch halt nichts an deswegen denke
ich mir so natürlich könnt ihr fragen
habt warum hast du die farbe die haare
gefärbt aber wenn ich dann so was höre
ja dass sie der total scheiße aus oder
auch so bei mir es war sommer es war
richtig heiß es waren 30 grad ich in
meinem zimmer der ich hatte damals eine
große glasfront und da kommt halt extrem
viel sonnenschein und wärme der
dementsprechend auch durch und dann habe
ich mir echt so gekommen ist einfach
hier oben drauf steht man sich da halten
paar mal so in tanktops tanktop diese
unter unterhemd ähnlichen teile da und
da hat mir dann so gar nichts gedacht
weil ich dachte ja ok tanktop wien soll
das interessieren so ich sitze halt
einfach so dass mein style und saß dann
da und hab' aufgenommen und dann kamen
alle hahn und mainz öl mach mal nicht
hier mit mit deinen tanktop und so du
hast ja gar keine muskeln und so da
denke ich mir nur so ja okay ich weiß
ich bin nicht gerade der muskulöse oder
breiteste mensch oder so aber mir ist
warm und deswegen tagen tanktop und ihr
sollt quasi das video schauen einfach
denn meine nase so quasi da sind schon
viele darauf eingegangen auch unter dem
video die man dann auch so hey das geht
euch nichts an und so ihr schaut die
videos und passt also nach dem motto und
ich möchte natürlich auch dass ihr mit
mir halt so
jetzt kommt dieser motorradfahrer wieder
ich glaube es nicht
vollidiot jetzt hab ich die ganze zeit
und saxofonist neben mir vor der tür
sitzen saxophon spielt und jetzt auch
noch so ein junger wein
wie kann der so viel sprit haben dass
der seit zwei stunden von meinen appell
die ganzen erfährt man heißen es nach
als sieg abo no no no you can't trägt
mich ich muss jetzt irgendwelche anderen
haider suchen
ich wurde als erstes gebiet nur
umgekehrt wie sie mit ihm verzeihe ich
mir dann einfach so wenn ich im tanktop
ihr sitzt oder so dann sicherheit im
tanktop und dann dann muss da nicht
jeder sagen sie mal entdeckt ob aus weil
ihr wisst ja nicht dass es bei mir dann
gerade 35 grad im zimmer ist und ja also
einfach dieses jahr kommen dass das ist
zwar ganz cool dass er sagt ja du hast
ja keine muskeln und so was alles aber
ich denke einfach nur es geht euch
nichts an was was ich halt quasi so wie
meine wie ich meine haare mache oder wie
ich will mich anziehe oder wie ich mich
benehmen oder irgendwie sowas weil es
ist halt meine art und ich bin einfach
wieder einen block vorbei gelaufen das
ist halt meine art das ist mein style so
mag ich das und ich denke wenn tadel
oder andere sich die haare färben wollen
dann ist das deren sache und das ist
deren style also ich persönlich würde
jahre nicht in dem ton fernen das muss
wirklich sagen aber ich sage auch nicht
an zutaten oder schreibt mir die
kommentare hier machst du dort macht mal
wieder anders und so was alles ist viel
besser aus dass dadurch noch mal genauso
wenn man sagt das hat vorher viel besser
aus oder so was in die richtung das ist
doch selbst seine sache ob er es gut
findet oder nicht und wenn das gemacht
hat findet er es wahrscheinlich gut
deswegen ich denke mir dann immer nur
soja schön kühl abstauben schöne
klatsche ich habe keinen knopf gestorben
ich denk mir in solchen momenten halt
immer nur was gehts euch an also das
soll jetzt kein held sein gegen euch bei
mir war das nur wirklich unter dem tank
top video einmal wo ich ein tanktop an
hat und seitdem habe ich mich noch nicht
wieder getraut und tanktop in einem
video anzusehen weil alle wieder so rum
gefilmt haben und es kommt halt auf das
video noch nicht auf die das aussehen
der person
das hatte tadel auch schon gesagt ich
nehme jetzt einfach da
als beispiel weil es mir danach halt
auch zu extrem aufgefallen ist das hatte
auch schon gesagt es kommt halt wirklich
bei youtube das video auch noch nicht
auf die person also klar wenn jetzt im
fernsehen gegenseitig die haare färbt
würde würde jeder direkt zu halten
was geht denn da färbt sich die haare
aber bei youtube sind wir alles einzelne
personen und machen das worauf er bock
haben deswegen machen wir youtube
deswegen ist jeder anders und keiner
versteht sich und jeder hat auch seinen
eigenen style von gmail hier ist die
ganze zeit geboxt alter was soll das ich
habe die ganze zeit die boxer oben
irgendwie das kann diese ach das sind
einfach nur diese komischen zu freuen
ich hoffe ich konnte euch so in etwa ein
bisschen sagen was ich euch mitteilen
euch sage was ich denke ihr wisst was
ich meine und ich denke auch dass ihr
das verstehen und respektieren können
weil er eigentlich leute seid die ganz
tolerant die man schon demgegenüber sind
also ich muss echt sagen ich bin froh
dass ich euch als prämien und ihr habt
die nicht so gar nicht so arg auf auf
irgendwie was ich hier mache um reihte
aber ich denke mal einfach nur so wenn
ihr seht dass irgendwas schreibt so ja
was soll das denn wieso trägst du denn
da was von der marke oder wieso machst
du dies oder das mit klamotten kann man
echt am besten immer als beispiel nehmen
dann schreibt ihn einfach jetzt doch
seine sache was er macht oder so und das
soll halt wirklich jetzt nicht so sein
dass ich euch allen sage ja ihr dürft
nicht sagen du siehst scheiße aus oder
irgendwie so das ist natürlich eine
meinung aber ihr solltet auf jeden fall
nichts was sagen so ziehe dich mal
anders an oder irgendwie sowas in der
richtung her denke ich einfach nur so
ihr guckt das video weil das video
interessant ist und weil er mich mögt
und wenn ihr dann sagten den style finde
ich total scheiße jetzt mal was anderes
anderen denk ich mir einfach nur sony
weil es ist mein style und ich mag das
und ich möchte youtube so machen wie es
mag und ich mache es auch nur weil ich
es mag und bin auf jeden fall nicht auf
irgendein angewiesen weil dann jemand
sagt jetzt mal knapp an alster nicht
dass ich gern denkt doch mehr anziehen
also ich hoffe ich konnte euch das sagen
dass ihr so youtube so ein bisschen
wieder zurück lenkt in die schiene ja
das sind ganz normale leute die haben
ihre eigenen style die machen das was
ihnen gefällt
angst und weg von diesem
ansehen immer so wie er ist ein star der
hat jetzt was anderes an einem video da
müssen die rag drauf um hacken und alles
posten darüber ob alles da denken wir
einfach nur so kommt es ist halt einfach
eine private sache wie man sich anzieht
wie man sich verhält oder irgendwie
sowas macht deswegen ich würde einfach
sagen das was für das video wenn es euch
gefallen hat würde ich mich über
definitiv über eine bewertung freuen
wenn er der meinung seid wie ich und
sonst würde ich sagen schreib doch mal
eure meinung in die kommentare wir sehen
uns einem anderen video wieder deuce